good morning everybody and welcome to
this informal meeting of the joint order
and standards committee
i am councillor brynn huron and i will
be chair in this meeting today
the decision to hold an informal meeting
has been taken as a result of the
current risks relating to the covert 19
pandemic
as this meeting is now an informal
meeting
members will not be
able to make decisions and therefore
there will be no voting on any items on
the agenda
members are asked to debate the items on
the agenda and to confirm a steer for
each item
which will be recorded and decisions may
then be taken by officers or the leader
under delegation depending on the
decision
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may have to be asked to
leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
please note that messages in the chat
panel may be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this informal meeting is broadcast
live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be infilmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you were also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of these images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
as for introductions i will announce the
governance offer to carry out the
introductions
mandy please
thank you chair um i believe the
officers in um in attendance today are
rebecca hewitt
um who will be presenting um our first
item
um
catherine steele
and who will be presenting um
our third item and emily yule
who's the monitoring officer
we do have other offices in attendance
but they are democratic services
officers
okay thank you mindy
do we have any apologies please
no apologies chair
thank you
uh could i receive declaration of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members are there any to declare
no i can't see any hands raised thank
you
notification of petitions are there any
mandy non-chair
thank you
questions by the public
thank you i will now move to the main
body of the meeting um
item six
paper irj 2115 joint capital investment
and treasury management
and i think rebecca rebecca hurt you're
going to introduce this for us please
go ahead
apologies chair counselor barrett has
her hand up
yep sorry melanie yes
sorry just before we do start on that um
could i just mention the minutes from
the 27th of november
which we often agree are accurate before
uh going into the main body
as this is an informal meeting we're
unable to take any formal votes so those
minutes will be taken to the next
meeting right just i do have a something
to note on those thank you
is it uh is it something urgent melanie
or will it wait
i'm sure it will wait it's not going to
change any anything so yes i'll make a
note of that for next time
thank you
yep thank you
um
back to rebecca then please good morning
rebecca
good morning thank you chair
okay so this is the joint capital
investment and treasury management
strategies for 2022-23
this report um
there have been no significant changes
in format this year from previous years
and it has been updated to reflect the
latest capital expenditure investment
and borrowing and the latest treasury
management investment and borrowing
positions of the councils
under the sitfir treasury management
code of practice and the prudential code
both published in 2021
investment guidance published in 20 in
2018 we are required to determine
separate capital investment and treasury
management strategy statements and
prudential indicators annually before
the start of each financial year
i'll just now quickly run you through
the appendices
so in appendix a we have the capital
strategy which summarizes the capital
expenditure and fire financing
requirements of the full capital program
for both the general fund and the hra
and the details of which are in the
budget report
this sets out capital expenditure and
investment decisions and the associated
risks and rewards along with how risk is
managed for future financial
sustainability
it includes the prudential indicators
which demonstrate that the investment
plans for the councils are affordable
prudent and sustainable and that
decisions are made in accordance with
good practice
this shows that capital expenditure
planned for 22 23 including carry
forwards is 41.1 million for baber of
which 22.9 will be funded by borrowing
and 68.2 million for mid-suffolk of
which 52.6 million will be funded by
borrowing
limits and boundaries for borrowing are
set as part of the prudential indicators
the strategy shows that projected
borrowing will not exceed these limits
appendix b is the investment strategy
this details those expenditure items in
the capital program that specifically
relate to assets bought
and or owned by the councils purely or
partially to generate a return
this does include schemes which have the
purpose of regeneration or development
as well as generating a return
in the context of this strategy
investments means those non-treasury
management activities
these are defined as two types of
investments so we have service provision
where the councils lend to or buy shares
in organizations that provide a service
such as gateway 14 for the purpose of
regeneration and economic development
and we also have investments for yield
where the primary purpose is to generate
a return such as the council-owned
company cifco
the strategy explains how each
investment contributes to the council's
priorities and their security liquidity
and risk it shows the projected total
investments of the councils in cifco the
growth companies and gateway 14 and also
planned expenditure on the council's
property held at least in part for
investment purposes
appendix c is the treasury management
strategy for 2223 it sets out the
council's borrowing requirement and
borrowing and treasury management
investment strategies
this also includes the list of approved
counterparties and limits there's been
no significant change to limits since
last year
appendix d is the treasury management
indicators which we use to measure and
manage the council's exposure to
treasury management risks
and appendix e is an economic update and
interest rate forecast
the ongoing impact on the uk from
covid19 together with higher inflation
the likelihood of higher interest rates
and the council's trade position
post-brexit will be major influences on
the council's treasury management
strategy for 2223
authorities treasury management advisor
arne close is forecasting that bank of
england base rate will rise to 0.5 in
the quarter of first quarter of 2022 and
remain at this level until at least the
final quarter of 2024
the risks to the forecast are initially
weighted to the upside but becoming more
balanced over time
appendix f shows the current investment
and debt portfolio with the position at
30th of november 2021
babies borrowing is currently 118.7
million of which 94.7 million is pwlb
and 24 million is short-term
for mid-suffolk the level is 132.9
million
105.4 of which is long-term and 27.5
million short-term
on the investment side baber has 21.6
million and mid-south at 19.75 million
including ccla ubs schroeder's infostec
and funding circle
we have continued the policy of
withdrawing funds from funding circle as
loans drop out and we have not invested
any new money
appendix b sets out the treasury
management policy statement which
underpins the strategy and sets out both
councils regards the monitoring of risk
and performance
appendix h contains the minimum revenue
provision statement which shows the
basis on how we put aside resources to
repay debt in later years
i must apologize but since this report
was published for this meeting we have
received some feedback from our treasury
advisors on in close
and updated figures with more recent
information resulting from work on the
budget and links to the budget report
there are some changes which will be
included in the strategies taken to
council in february which i will now
take you through
most of the changes are to provide more
clarity around the council service
investments and commercial investments
commercial investments are primarily for
financial return and under the new 2021
prudential code an authority must not
borrow to invest primarily for financial
return
so i'll take you through through these
changes now
so in appendix a for the capital
strategy in paragraph 2.12
there is a statement that has been added
in um that the section 151 officer
considers that none of these projects
count as investment assets primarily for
yield under the pwlb lending
arrangements nor as investments
primarily for financial return under the
sit for prudential code
paragraph
4.5 under appendix a table 6
this is the prudential indicator for
gross debt and capital financing
requirement
these have been reformatted to show the
head room for both the hra and general
fund uh separately
for both boehring and the cfr
so for baber 3.27 million of the head
room in each year relates to the hra
with the remainder for the general fund
and for mid-suffolk
24.98 million from 22 23 onwards relates
to the hra and the revised tables will
show this separately from the general
fund
still in appendix a paragraph 4.10 table
7 the borrowing and the liability
benchmark
we had some advice from our treasury
management advisors arlene close that
only existing debt should be included
and not expected debt from future
capital expenditure within this
indicator
and so this has increased the gap
between the actual borrowing and the
liability benchmark
paragraph 4.12 appendix a table 8
prudential indicators
the ratios have been corrected and as
they had been previously miscalculated
so for
2223 it's now 67.6
23 24
percent
24.25 now 71.6
and 25.6
72.2 percent
within the
same appendix paragraph 4.1 the charts
um showing the borrowing compared to the
cfr liability benchmark
have now been updated for the the same
amendment in paragraph 4.10 so for only
including existing borrowing and not
future planned borrowing as advised by
our treasury advisors
paragraph
an appendix b the joint investment
strategy and paragraph 1.2 has been
added to um to to distinguish between
investments for purely commercial
purposes and investments for
regeneration
so it's been added to say both councils
are working to complete housing
developments including the sites of the
formal council offices in hadley need a
market through the council's trading
companies weber growth limited and
mid-suffolk growth limited
mid suffolk has also invested in its
subsidiary gateway 14 limited for the
purposes of regeneration and economic
development
for a similar reason paragraph 3.3 table
1
the hadley
a1071 roadside commercial workspace
development and we have renamed a1071
economic development to clarify that
this is not a purely commercial
investment
but also has economic development
purposes
and then in appendix b paragraph 9.5
table 6 investments net rate of return
the latest gateway 14 forecast figures
for 23 24 to 25 26 have been updated um
in the mid suffolk table
so this is now showing in 2324 it's 5.3
percent
24.25
5.77
and 25 26 6.69
percent
finally in appendix c in the joint
treasury management strategy
um in paragraph 3.3 table 1 um similar
to some of the other amendments the
babies external borrowing figures have
been corrected to include existing
borrowing only
and so external borrowing has reduced by
14 million in 21.2 in 21
22-25-26 okay so that's all for me so
happy to take questions thank you chair
thank you very much rebecca
um lot to go through there i think for
ease i'll probably split the appendices
out um
maybe append to see a questions on that
then b then c
because that is the main bulk of the um
papers
and then the following ones may be all
together just for clarity
i know what you say um rebecca and this
the additions will all be put in and i
present this to full council weren't
they because yes there is quite a lot i
hope that members can just
remember the more made note as i have
i was going to highlight four six and
four seven in your summary um rebecca
that um
investment for gain is no longer um
really encouraged but it seems to be
quite frowned upon isn't it but what we
have invested that that's okay that's
safe we don't have to um rejig that in
any way i take it no we don't no it's
just future future investment
yep okay thanks very much so let's take
questions on um
appendix a first just for clarity i've
got dave and then james dave first
please
um thank you very much chair uh rebecca
referring to the table on capital
expenditure on page 12
i noticed the actual turn for capital
investments 2021 was 21.32 million yet
the forecast for 20 21 22 is only 4.11
million
is there any particular reason for that
vast difference please
um i
i would have to take that away i'm
afraid and have a look into that yes
i'll say i might i might be able to
assist with that that question chair um
my thinking is that it's linked to the
final investment in cifco
because we did the final investment of
the
second chance of 25 million in 2021 so
that would have been a higher level of
capital expenditure that year
compared to to the current financial
year
thank you very much catherine thank you
chair
i had james
please
thank you very much chair
um
so the next page page 13 the um table
two
um
when we have
grants and um
and also um
uh external contribution predictions for
years up to the 25th to
25-26 um
how are we um
how we knowing that we're going to get
summoned well i assume the ones that are
on zero that could potentially be grants
but we we don't know what they are yet
um so that's a very difficult one but
when we've got
forecast um grants like maybe the the
first one there baber
0.76
um
up until um 25 26 what is that and how
and how do we know we're gonna get it
yep okay so i believe that's um 0.76 is
the disabled facilities grant that we
get on a regular basis for doing
disabled
disabled
adaptions to to properties so that is a
regular
um ongoing ongoing grant that we get
from central government which is why we
have included included that
right okay thank you very much um and um
the um
on page 19
um
well it's table eight on page nine well
the
it's nice four point one two um we're
looking at the um
the sort of 15 million pound buffer
um
where we um
the authorized limit
um where do we get 15 million pounds for
and how do we come to that figure it
seems a lot of money
so um yeah could i could you just give
me a bit of background to that please
yes certainly so the operational
boundary is linked to our capital
financing requirement um for the
authorized limit we put the 15 million
pounds on as a
um as you say as a buffer for cash flow
purposes so it may be that we're waiting
for a grant to come in or we have to pay
out money in advance of getting income
in so
um
that authorized limit has been set i
don't know if catherine has any
further information on why it's 15
million
i don't think it's a mathematical
calculation it's just uh based on our
level of borrowing and let you say to
give us that headroom should there be
any sort of unexpected circumstances
that arise that we just need need
um that
extra ability
my experience probably for a number of
years as i don't think we tend to even
go above our operational boundary
so um we haven't had to invoke that
authorized limit but it is there just to
give us some
as you say some headroom and a bit of a
buffer so that we don't have to come
back to council in managing you know the
day-to-day treasury management of the
council it just gives us that that
flexibility should we need it but say my
experience is we we haven't needed to
use it in the past
right so yeah so that could easily have
been one million for the last few years
and um it wouldn't have made any
difference
to
anything yeah we're not going into it
okay thank you very much
thank you james mary your question
please
thank you chair oh
trying to bring thee oh right there we
are we're working morning rebecca
um like i've got two questions related
to
uh item nine in appendix a
which is about the knowledge and skills
that uh we purchase
um my first question is
that those i mean there's ten
subcontractors listed there
why
can we not develop some of those i know
you can't develop all skills but the
first question is why can we not develop
some of those skills in-house
okay
do you want me to yeah let's
start to start with that one rebecca um
some of these are very specialist and uh
it's not um i suppose cost-effective
usually for us to have somebody and and
to be honest it's sometimes very
difficult to recruit to a local
authority those types of skills um we
have a certain number of skills in-house
i mean we have you know emily a tech as
you know um has a vast range of
knowledge and experience certainly in
the property sector
but there are some times where we just
need that extra expertise
as for treasury management we use our
link close you know who are operating in
the market every day so with some of our
other developments or investments
certainly on the property side you know
in terms of cifco then we have always
brought in
that specialist expertise because
yes we might want to try and develop
some of that but it does take many years
doesn't it to get to that that level of
expertise that we're wanting to to rely
on so um i know certainly in emily a tax
area she has brought more staff on board
that have got more of those skills so it
may be you know in time that we can rely
a bit less on some of those external
consultants but obviously the nature of
what we were entering into we wanted to
make sure that the council had the right
advice you know in terms of those
investments so i think it's i think it's
always a balance to be honest in terms
of
what you can develop internally and you
know um
whether that's needed 100 of the time or
whether it is say more cost effective to
purchase the advice when you need it
so thank you uh catherine my second
question then follows on from that
um do we have a sort of combined
uh cost for because obviously we're
going to be we're still retaining these
people in in the forth coming years
so for 22 23 do we have a projected cost
of what these external contractors are
going to
charge us
i don't have that information i'm
guessing rebecca probably won't either
because some of that goes through the
companies
um and obviously goes through their
accounts so
we don't have absolute visibility of all
of that detail um it's a question we
could take away and see whether we we
could provide a bit more information for
the committee
well it would be interesting i mean i i
i was just thinking how much it was
because in fact these
subcontractors are just
the elitist group if you like aren't
they of lots of other subcontractors and
it would be interesting to know actually
how much we pay
uh subcontractors for the whole count
well obviously for baber district
council as far as i'm concerned
so
i was gonna say it's quite it's quite a
difficult figure to get to because it is
i say it's scattered across all of the
service areas and the companies as well
but we'll certainly we'll take that
question away and see if we can uh pull
something together
thank you thank you catherine can thank
you rebecca thank you chair
thank you mary uh mike please mike
norris you have a question
[Music]
uh thank you chair yes i have two
questions
i'm looking at uh page 16
estimates of capital financing
requirement
and in the mid suffolk section
bottom line totals
comparing 20 21 stroke 22 forecast out
turn
194 million
to to a 20 22 23 budget 245 million i
can see that the hra line has also
jumped up but are there any other
factors in that
yes certainly so within the capital
investments um a a chunk of that will be
related to gateway 14 and planned
expenditure on on that project i think
that will be the the biggest element of
that yes i expected that actually yes
okay thank you
and the second question i have relates
to page 22
tell me while i just find it on my other
screen
paragraph 7.2
proportion of financing cost to net
revenue stream
comparing
baba which starts off
at
18.26 percent and then
declines to 14.21
whereas mid-south starts off at
19.17 and then increases
year on year up to 38.11
is there a simple answer to that
okay thank you for the question um i
don't know if there is a simple answer
again i think that will be partly
influenced by gateway 14
and the way that the um income
is reduces in later years but i'd
probably have to take that one away
okay and have a look at that one okay
thank you
thank you mike
um
no more questions i can see
generally um
rebecca catherine um i wondered if um
we could have a comment on six one the
pension deficit just
there's lots of
new councillors here who may not be
aware
um
the deficit for weber is 28 million mid
suffolk 40. does this affect
final
payout
salaries i can't believe it does and i
can see we do to put some in but um
i think my question is will we ever
catch up and
how
i wonder if you could just give us um
a brief sort of appraisal of this please
it's worrying for me but probably not
for you can you reassure us
yes sir certainly chair um yeah the the
pension
deficit has been there for a number of
years and it and it fluctuates to be
honest depending on what the stock
market is doing
uh the last because we have we have um
what called triennial valuations of the
pension fund
um the last one was in 2019
and at that point the the actual
valuation of the fund had improved so it
had got closer to a hundred percent
in terms of its funding
uh the next one is due as at march 22 so
not that far away at the moment and at
the moment the the stock market is uh
looking quite good so i think everyone
is perhaps anticipating that this next
valuation of the pension funds will
improve it again
and i know one or two funds even at the
last valuation had finally reached the
100 percent
funding limit so
um based on where we're currently at
then over the last three years we have
been able to make a small reduction in
our contribution each year
the figure that we put in the accounts
is sort of a very much a snapshot in
time as at the 31st of march of each
particular financial year
but yes
the funds generally i think both ours
and across the country are moving in the
right direction because employers have
put these extra contributions in over a
number of years now
and just picking up your point about
does it affect the final payments no it
doesn't
um the local authority pension scheme is
such that it's a
defined benefit scheme so irrespective
of the money that is in the fund at the
point any person retires then what their
benefits are paid is is determined by by
statute in fact you know by the
national local government pension scheme
for local authorities hopefully
hopefully that answers your question
chair and and gives you some reassurance
perhaps of the direction of travel that
we're going in
yes thank you catherine it did sort of
as i expected um we all know investments
go down as well as up so we
hope for the latter and read the former
okay that's something to be kept an eye
on because obviously if it gets too far
out we may be expected to make up the
difference or supplement it um
thank you that that's pretty clear nope
for everybody else as well
um mike is that an old hand or you've
you've taken it down now any more
questions on appendix a
members
no move to appendix b then um
page 25 any points or questions on that
before we
go to discussion
anybody
i think i had one while i'm waiting for
the hands to come up if they do
no mine was on appendix c anything on
appendix
b anybody
no we'll take that as read then appendix
c
um page 37.
james
would you like to kick off please thank
you chairman i'm i'm really sorry could
we go back to appendix b because i've
got all these papers printed out and
then different sections all over my desk
and it just took me a while to um
to get to where i was on appendix speak
um that's fine james of course again i
was trying to make it easier and i
probably made it hard but um
you were fine i was very slow mr
chairman
um so um we had an update on the sifko
um i didn't quite catch
exactly where rebecca said that the
update was she couldn't just go through
them
um the um the changes to the sifko
um
yeah do you know what i mean rebecca
um let's have a look um so
for sifko
i don't believe there are any changes to
the
numbers for cifco within appendix b
um
oh okay so there's no changes to those
no that's that's happening no
numbers i think there was there was some
wording to tighten up um to clarify that
we weren't investing any further in it
but no no changes to the figures first
okay i thought i didn't get it down in
time but no there wasn't so um thank you
very much yeah
thank you chairman
thank you james ever anything
independent say
um
no i'll um
i'll just go through it now and just
have a look but thank you okay okay
um rebecca just from me um we're
expecting a rise in
interest rates aren't we um
and it possibly could go quite steep i
heard you mention half a percent um
if it went up to say 0.1 what difference
would that make um because obviously
we've got more
borrowing than than investments haven't
we
you know could you give me a ballpark
figure of what a rise like that what
difference it would make on the plus and
minus um
columns
um yes i don't have those
figures to hand um
it's just a rather feel by the end of
this year that could be possibly the
sort of rates we're at and i just
wondered if you've thought about that
basically
um
if
if that's too much um plucking out of
the sky um rebecca um
you know come back to me in writing
afterwards maybe but i just feel it's
something but the end of this coming
financial year we could be dealing with
and um
maybe we just ought to be aware of that
yeah certainly
thank you
um
now james has shuffled his papers again
do you have a question
i think yeah we're about 140 pages for
um
um the these two items on the agenda so
sorry i just something that's fine
my system got got a little bit out of
shape um
so we talked about um in appendix c 5.9
the negative interest rates which um
we've had in there for um
for a couple of years now but um do you
think that's still
something relevant that we need to be
thinking about now
thank you for your question i think
now um we've recognized that it is much
less likely than perhaps it was during
the initial part of the covid pandemic
and we have still left it in information
so that we've have the clarity over what
would happen if we were in that that
instance in the future but i do believe
that is
is now across the market seen as
unlikely
yeah i do um i do wonder if it's time
for that to come out but i know it
doesn't do any harm being in but um i i
don't i don't think it's particularly
relevant but thank you very much
okay thank you james i don't have any
more um questions on this so i'll invite
questions for um
appendices d
e f and g that's everything else they're
smaller dependencies but
i'm sure somebody may have picked up
something um
dave yes far away yeah just a quickie
thank you chair uh on appendix f on page
62. this is the existing borrowing and
investments um treasury investments bank
and banks and building societies where
we've invested 1.62 million but the
average percentage rate is zero
um which seems is that because they're
like a current account and there's no
interest paid on that account
i noticed we've got 0.01 on money market
funds and 5.03 on other pooled funds
i was just really curious why that was a
zero percent on the banks and building
societies please rebecca yep certainly
um we've said they are
generally um i think that's the
dmadf
fund from primarily from central
government and that has had very very
low rates and it has actually been zero
for most most of this year
um so that is there that is sort of our
our account of last resort as a as a
safe place when all our money market
funds are are full so
that is just very low very very low
rates at this at this time
thank you very much rebecca thank you
chair
thank you dave is there anything else
from anyone else in all the rest of the
papers
um on this paper
no that looks like everyone is
reasonably happy
well we cannot vote but i'm looking for
a steer that everybody's happy on the
recommendations that
is it your wish that we accept um
what we've all read and discussed or
does anyone want to have more of a
discussion on this we're in the
discussion mode now
any hands please
yes i've got dave and then mary um
dave let's hear from you first
yeah i'm i'm broadly happy with the
recommendations
as stated thank you chair
thank you and
mary next
yes
i'm um
very happy with it and just sort of
comment on the
the work that's gone in by the team
because it's been the most horrendous
two years hasn't it
and so all credit to
uh the section 151 officer and all her
team with the work that's gone into this
report thank you chair
thank you mary mike you wish to make a
comment
uh well yes i would also like to commend
the officers it must have been a
bit of a nightmare actually i think
pulling these figures together for this
last year um and i'm quite happy to go
with the recommendations thank you
yes thank you mike well we don't need of
a proposal or a secondary um
for this just general agreement that
we're on the um the right track these
figures will be amended a little um as
rebecca pointed out for the full council
meetings but
um all being there i think we have a
good stare steer to go forward
thank you very much everybody
now item
seven um
jac 2116
adoption of the new
suffolk code of conduct that we all have
to obey
emily can you introduce this please i
can see you're smiling it's power isn't
it
thank you chair good morning councillors
i'm pleased to introduce this report
which asks the committee to recommend
that the full council has adopted the
new local government association model
code of conduct
as the committee will be aware this
model code has been developed by the
local government association following
the recommendations by the committee on
standards in public life
there has been significant national
consultation with councillors and
monitoring officers and sector experts
have been involved in drafting both the
revised code
and the supporting guidance
the main features and alterations to the
new model code are outlined in the body
of the report
there have been no changes to the
sanctions available to the monitoring
officer as this would require
legislative change and currently there
is really no appetite from the
government to make those changes
the suffolk monitoring officers group
have discussed this revised code at
length and are recommending it to each
of the county district and borough
councils
in terms of each of those councils
adopting the code in full so as
published by the lga
we will also be recommending alongside
the suffolk association of local
councils that town and parish councils
in suffolk also adopt the new model code
and this will ensure that we continue to
have a consistent code of conduct across
all tiers of local authorities in
suffolk which as i've mentioned to this
committee before
is really important um both for me as a
monitoring officer given that i
investigate code of conduct complaints
across
town and parish councils and the
district councils but also for those
councillors who represent more than one
authority so that there is consistency
and that there's
a common understanding of the code of
conduct
chairman i'm very happy to answer any
questions that committee members may
have thank
you thank you emily
um i think i should perhaps remind
everybody that we are um
order and standards committee so we do
have a responsibility we don't try our
own but obviously if
somebody from neighbouring councils um
steps over the line it can come to us to
um
to investigate this matter fully and try
and recommend some um
i won't say punishments um
you know please don't do it again sort
of rules
and we have done that in the past so i
have a fairly good understanding of what
is required i think
because the ones we've had i've always
chaired and i think we've always had a
very good result
mainly people have to apologize um
sometimes in front of their councils
which i think is
a good outcome and the commitment not to
do it again so there are some teeth
behind this um
i sometimes think for
the real
um
nasty one shall i say the punishment
maybe she'll be a bit more but we're
limited what we can do but we do have a
responsibility um for standards as well
i've read through the paper and i've got
nothing to add to it emily it's
absolutely excellent i think
it covers everything um
uh i bit concerned sometimes about the
parishes they tend to forget
we're a bit more responsible but they
can easily forget and sometimes do but
hopefully it will um all turn out well
right questions james and then mary
james first please
thank you very much mr chairman yes i
was going to um i was going to say a
similar thing here because obviously
this is a um
this code of conduct isn't uh the
council's work this is something we're
looking to adopt that many other
councils have adopted it um already um
and um it's um
it's yeah it's it's a good piece of work
i looked through this and i think
everything in here i completely agree
with and morally i think
yes it's um it's exactly the way we
should be behaving as um counselors um
it's good to have it in
print though to make sure
that um as a sort of guideline the um
i was i was interested in the gifts and
hospitality section where um
a um
a counselor needs to um
register
a gift even if they refuse it
which seems um quite an interesting um
concept really um
because um
obviously we
if um if there's a register somewhere
saying all the lots lots of gifts have
been offered but not taken you could
easily damage your accounts reputation
you know there absolutely is
doing everything exactly like they
should but that was the only part of
this but obviously
that is in a in a situation where
somebody's trying to um bring about the
downfall of a counselor and just give
them a way of
of doing it but i think that
that that's a bit far-fetched but yeah
really good and going for i will happily
um adopt this as a council member
yeah thank you very much
thank you james do you want to comment
on that aspect um emily because i think
that
that is a slightly strange one i can see
why it's in there
um yes thanks chair it's it's really um
a provision that actually exists in um
officer code of conducts already um so
officers are required to
declare gifts that are not accepted and
it's really that transparency element so
you know if somebody is um if a third
party is trying to offer um a gift for
their own game this is to protect the
council and the councillor by saying you
know it was offered but refused um so in
many ways i think it's a positive thing
and i think um
as monitoring officer i would see it as
a sign of
good behavior on behalf of the
councillor that they had to refuse gifts
opposed to seeing it as something that
could be used to discredit or undermine
a counsellor so um i think it's all part
of that transparency code and
you know the reality is that it would
come up um very rarely in any case
because councillors are not very often
um offered gifts and hat and hospitality
um
in any case
um
i was offered a turkey once many years
ago which i refused but um
not much has come my way also i suppose
emily if one person was constantly
offering
gifts to councillors across the board it
would um it would flag up we need to be
alert about that person wouldn't that so
um
i take that on board as well mary
morning emily
um
i loved it actually
i i thought it was brilliant
but uh i've got two questions really one
is um
where are we in the scheme of say all
these suffolk councils are we
ahead of the game in in
accepting this or
other councils beating us to it
um so we're all trying to coordinate our
meetings um so that we can achieve
adoption at approximately the same time
um but obviously each council has got a
different um
schedule of meetings and they have a
different route in so some councils have
a committee that they would go to before
council and others would go straight to
to council um the um idea or the
timetable that we're working to is that
the principal councils would adopt the
code by march um and this is
particularly relevant for ipswich
borough council who elect in thirds and
do have elections um in may and then the
town and parish councils could adopt the
code in may at their annual town and
parish council meetings
thank you now the the second thing i'm
not sure it's the question or a
statement i am cons like um brin
i am concerned not about every parish
council
but about the very small parish councils
and i identified four areas um
that could actually deter them
from actually having the
i think the training especially
um i don't know if you've got a view how
how can i as a ward member
enable or empower parish my parish
councils
to achieve this code because
for one of my parishes it is
impossible
for them to actually adopt this for
various reasons because they can't
actually access the training
and perhaps don't have the money for the
the money the time and
um
for training is just impossible for some
parish councils how do we how do we
as ward members and does this committee
try and influence that thank you
so um in lots of ways the code isn't
that far removed from the code that town
and parish councils have already adopted
so we already have the suffolk wide
local code of conduct and many of the
provisions are
uh either the same or very similar but
this what this new code does is it
provides further contexts and
description to what those provisions
mean
and particularly the guidance notes
give examples of how the code would be
applied
and how it would be interpreted so
there's some real benefits to taking
this enhanced version if you like
in terms of training we'll be working
very closely with the suffolk
association of local councils to provide
training
and some councils will as members of
that uh group already have access to
that training
we're also thinking as a group of
monitoring officers about how we could
um run training whether that might be
through recording some training or
through e-learning so trying to make
lots of
um different ways for counselors to
access training and to access the
guidance and in ways that are accessible
and relatively cheap and also bearing in
mind
that not every council has
uh you know a proper officer a parish
clerk that
that works for for a larger number of
hours and has the capacity themselves to
roll out the training so we're looking
at different ways to do that and to
support
parish councils um and we're also um
thinking about particular parish
councils who might need some additional
support we would go out to them on a
one-to-one basis so
trying to kind of cover all areas and
support all all sizes of parish councils
um to adopt the same code um but we will
be having those conversations with them
in the lead up to them adopting it as
well
i would welcome that emily that is that
is very good for parish councils thank
you thank you chair
thank you mary
just stick over there emily it might be
quite good to brief district councillors
more that when they go out to their
parishes we probably ought to be doing
it sort of
as of next month and warner limits
coming and
trying to convince some of this
beneficial to have it i think that would
be um a good strategy as well you may be
planning it anyway because i know you're
sort of on the ball but
that might be an additional string to
the bow i would think
mike please
thank you chair uh i noticed uh in this
code the threshold for declaration of uh
receipt of gifts has been increased from
25 pounds to 50 pounds i've just been
trying to find what i'm just about to
refer to on my other screen um and that
is i had a feeling i can't find it now i
had a feeling that there was some
reference to the cumulative value of
gifts in any one period am i correct on
that
thank you
yes i think you're right councillor
norris there is a um
it's not just the value of a single gift
it's also if you receive lots of small
value gifts
uh from the same uh
giver then you should also um declare
that as as a as a value over 50 pounds
thank you emily can i just clarify when
you said from the same giver
but if you get a lot of small gifts from
different people over the same period
whether it be 12 months or whatever
does that also count
i don't think that's captured i can um
go back to the guidance and and have a
look at that but i think it is if you
receive multiple gifts from the same
person or the same organization
what i would say though is that actually
we encourage our our members to uh
record all all gifts no matter what the
value just for that um absolute
transparency and openness that's right
i'm aware of that one yes it was just to
clarify this cumulative
gifts angle whether it was from you know
different givers over
is it every 12 months presumably on this
declaration no yes that's fine okay if
you can just come back on that one at
that point i'd be very grateful thank
you i will too that's always psycho
you're happy to receive that out of
meeting are you mike
sorry yes indeed thank you yeah that's
good yes
melanie please
thank you chair um
emily i i just an interesting area for
me is um thinking about the defining the
code for members that are still in
employment or self-employment
um
and the sort of spillover between those
two areas
uh where there might be a public element
to to their their work
a lot of employment we wouldn't have any
sort of
insight into at all and how they conduct
themselves but some some employment
might
and can we expect to extend that code
into how they conduct themselves within
their
other employment where it might reflect
on their their work as counsellor or our
council
um
so
any thoughts on that and how how that
can be applied it's a it's a sort of
boundary
difficult boundary to draw isn't it but
um
how can you guess that
thank you council about that's a really
interesting point um because obviously
there will be some um
professions where there's also a
professional code um that the person
adheres to and there may be some overlap
or or um some kind of uh
uh superseat that code supersedes the
code of conduct but the critical point
here it comes back to the capacity test
so the initial test um that we ask
ourselves when a code of conduct
complaint is received is uh does the
code apply in terms of was the counselor
acting in a an official capacity at the
time that the alleged behavior occurred
and this new model code of conduct
actually uh widens that capacity test um
so
uh almost under the current code uh the
presumption would be that you were not
acting as a counselor unless it was very
clear that you were acting in in that
capacity so either that the behavior
occurred
um at a council meeting or when you were
on a particular council business or when
you were writing um using the council's
social media or something like that
the shift that that has shifted under
this new model code to say actually you
will be presumed to be acting as a
counselor wherever there is any
link to your role as a counselor or
wherever an ordinary person would see
your um that that activity or what
you're writing on social media to come
from your perspective as a counselor so
it it widens that capacity test um so i
think more often you would be captured
by the code than not
but it still does
create that separation of if you're
doing something in a purely personal
capacity or a purely professional
capacity it wouldn't necessarily be
captured by the code of conduct if that
makes sense so it's it's a wider
it's a wider definition of capacity but
it still does allow for that separation
of roles
so i'm just just thinking of if if
someone is using um a social media uh or
that sort of platform and they're mostly
using it in one capacity perhaps as a
counselor to highlight issues
would that then mean that
most of what they post
and and talk about is
reflecting on their role as a counselor
then
yeah absolutely you know if it's a
social media so let's take social media
as an example because that i think
that's where it most commonly comes up
about this question of capacity if it's
a social media account that clearly
identifies that person as a counselor
you know they tend to use it for council
business
you know the assumption would be that
that is is um captured by the code of
conduct
if it's a personal account
but the counselor posts something where
they would only know about that issue
because they are a counsellor or they're
very clearly giving their view as a
counsellor that would also be captured
even though it's from a personal social
media account
okay thank you thanks for that
that's good
thank you melanie that's a very
difficult one isn't it i feel you know
what about if a counsellor works say for
a parish council
it's obviously separate billing um that
could be an issue as well at some point
couldn't
do you have a view on that emily
um
thanks chad i think um again my advice
would be about openness and transparency
in respect of of wearing those different
hats or having different roles um and so
part of that is obviously completing the
register of interest to clearly
demonstrate any uh
employment that you have or other roles
on other boards or bodies um but also
just being very clear um when you're
communicating or
you know
when you're representing views at a
meeting for example you know i'm here as
the district councillor or i am here as
the parish council employee so just be
being very um clear and transparent
about trying to separate those roles
wherever possible and also just being
very aware of when conflicts could arise
and stepping away from any decisions
where a counselor might be conflicted or
or
might not be able to approach that with
an open mind because of their their
other role
yes i think of supplying things to um
parish councils etc as a business but um
which is something i do i might provide
a notice board for a parish council you
see but it's definitely for my business
and builders such and i think they're
all right and i never put vote for bryn
all over them when i deliver them so um
i think i do manage to keep everything
very separate
okay everybody um any more questions um
and as to the decision part is it your
wish that we accept this and um
when will this go to um
council melanie will this it's not on
next week's one it'll be february when
it goes um to babel in mid-southwest is
that correct
it will come to the march for council
meetings no march okay fine then okay
fine um
dave
yes thank you chair yes i'm happy with
the recommendations as quoted in the
papers thank you
yes and that goes for me also emily very
much so and um
i know you don't need a proposal in a
second but if you want two people to
give a good clean bill of health um
you can take it from me as well haven't
um read through all of it
i see you put your hand up um mike and
then put it down again i assume you're
just endorsing that is that correct
yes that is correct thank you mr
chairman
yes thank you very much mike for your
support
okay then well that's agreed emily that
this goes to the march um
full council meeting with um the clean
bill health um
apart from maybe my comment that maybe
it needs as much publicity to um get it
through the paris councils um
as we can possibly give it but you've
already agreed so i'm very very happy
with that thank you emily thank you very
much thank you chair thank you
councillors
we move now to item eight
arrangement for the appointment of
external orders and i think catherine
you're gonna just take us through this
one so
if you like far ahead please thank you
yeah thank you chair
um and and just to say just on the back
of the the last conversation you were
having this recommendation we'll go into
the february council meeting um i'll
just explain that in a moment rather
than the march one so
just a short introduction on the report
our current five-year external audit
contract was let by the public sector
audit appointments
following a national procurement and the
councils both opted to join that in
2016.
our current contract through that
includes the audit of our
2022-23 accounts
and since 2018-19
both council's auditor has been ernst
and young
and that has been the case for all of
the other councils in suffolk as well
so we now need to decide and let psaa
know by the 11th of march
and that's why i was saying this one
needs to go into council in february if
we again wish to join the national
procurement exercise that they're
undertaking to let a further five-year
contract
so you've been asked to consider this
this morning and make a recommendation
to council
because this is a decision that is
reserved for council rather than this
committee
so there are three options outlined in
the report along with the respective
risks and benefits so the first one is
about the opt-in to the psaa option
there's also a second option there about
making a stand-alone appointment
and a third option in terms of setting
up an order to panel and having local
joint procurement arrangements with with
other authorities
now there have been some some national
issues over the last couple of years
with the timely completion of local
authority audits
um but my view is that i don't think
this is down to the national contract
arrangements there have been a variety
of factors that have
impacted that that timely completion
um and therefore i do believe that we
should coordinate coordinate our efforts
through the national arrangements with
other councils so that we can tackle all
these changes collectively
so the recommendation within the report
is to continue to opt in to the the psaa
option
uh one or two of the councils in suffolk
have already made their decision and
they will be opting into the psa
arrangement
and it looks like the others are likely
to do the same when they when they have
their council meetings as well so that
would mean that we wouldn't necessarily
have anyone locally that we could do a
joint procurement with if we wanted to
look at one of the other options
the lga's view is also that the the
national procurement remains the the
best option for local authorities and so
i would certainly support that for you
so that's really all what to say in
terms of introducing the report chair
and i'll be happy to answer any
questions thank you
thank you catherine um a question for me
do we have any um
option or choice in the cost or if we
opt in and
we have who we get and and we pay the um
ongoing rate i take it there's no
competitive um
aspect to this at all really is there
the competitive aspect is in terms of
the the contract procurement in the
first place because obviously the major
audit firms will be competing for those
contracts
so depending on what bids they actually
submit that that's where the competition
aspect uh comes
uh the psaa themselves are the body that
set the the fees each year so um and
that's been the case for a number of
years it's either been
psaa in recent years or the audit
commission before that so i say we've
we've never had the ability to to set
the fee level ourselves
i think the slight worry katherine is
that i'm not sure that um
these people really want to do it you
know they um it seems they're struggling
um to meet deadlines don't they and it's
something they do that probably um
incurs on other work they do that
i'm just i'm just sort of wondering
slightly how much they want to do it and
they may try and sort of
um hike the price to reflect that they
don't care one way or the other is is
that a reasonably fair assumption
um i think as i put in the report i
think there may be some increase in fees
compared to where fees currently are but
i think that was likely to happen
without the re-procurement nationally
because there are additional
burdens on audit firms and new
requirements that they have to comply
with so you know there there is more
that they have to do in terms of an
audit
um
this is big business so i can anticipate
that the big firms again will still be
interested um i know they have suffered
over the last couple of years you know
with having the right skills and
expertise and and losing staff but i
know all of them have been doing a big
recruitment campaign you know to try and
replace that so as say when you're
talking about the number of local
authorities across the country
this is still big big business for those
firms and and i'm sure they they must
make some return on the contract or else
they wouldn't be interested in bidding
for it and there certainly was the
interest last time around but it may
have a slight upwards pressure in terms
of the costs for this time around
okay thank you castle that's probably
enough from
myself how do um other people on the
committee think um quite important this
one james
thank you bryn um yeah i totally agree
with what um you just said i think we
got to be careful
with this particular contract that we um
we make sure that we're getting good
value for money um and it would be easy
um i think to
there's there's several um companies
that are able to do this kind of
um audit
um so
i think with something like this i'd
like to see at least three
sort of um
offers
um including definitely the psaa
but also other outside other you know
other um people capable of handling it
because um yeah for me i think we just
it's all about value for money and if we
can um if we can
actually compare
three different i just say three
different options because that's what i
think is sensible you you know you don't
want you don't want too many and i think
three is just about where we want to be
um we can um we can look at it and just
make sure that we're
getting that value for money
thank you
james thank you melanie
chair if i could just uh perhaps uh
clara clarify one point on that um the
option that i've recommended as the
preferred one of uh opting in with uh
psaa means that they would actually
undertake the procurement exercise so
they are the ones that would be seeing
the bids that once we've said if we're
gonna opt in then we wouldn't actually
have an involvement in the tendering
procurement exercise so um they would
obviously be the ones that see you know
get the comparisons from the audit firms
um there is actually a limited number of
audit firms that are registered to be
able to undertake
local government audits i think it may
be only about five of the the large
audit firms that they are registered to
undertake it
and i think the best option of getting
that value for money is being part of
the the national procurement because
you've then got
those economies of scale of us all
coming together so i think we're more
likely to get value from money that way
than if we if we tried to do something
locally ourselves
yes thank you catherine it is five it
was that a couple of years ago when i
went on the training and i don't think
it's changed so that is five yes melanie
please your viewers on this
yeah um i i think um the description of
the the modelling that the um
the offer that
ppsa um offer seems seems um a logical
move to to go towards that when you
consider how
inconvenient it could be to the council
to try and secure people with the
capacity and the the right skills to
form a um a sort of a a panel for
selecting a firm all quite sort of um
risky really as to whether we could even
secure that panel and then obtain the
the the bids and and scrutinize them
satisfactorily when you've got an oven
ready
system ready to go that will will
operate that and i presume they don't
charge a fee is that um there's no is
there a fee with uh
the um the public sector um option
no there isn't
yeah
so um i i think um i mean i'm not
hearing anything that deters me from um
going for that that um
uh sort of a model that that um seems
to be set up exactly how how we need it
to to operate to
to make our lives a bit a bit easier
so
thank you melanie well put mike please
thank you chair uh i'm looking at
recommendation 3.2
the psa are described as a sector-led
body and their full name is public
sector order appointments limited
my question is is this a company with a
limited liability then i'm
where
i'm thinking about the unlikely event of
this all going pear-shaped and who
actually makes up this
this company
that they are actually a very small
company that there is a government
appointed body that's been set up
and the government set them up as say
after the audit commission was
wound up so this is the body that
replaced so
say they are a government body
and they are actually quite a small i
couldn't tell you exactly how large they
are but i think the employees may
maybe a handful because when i've
contacted them in the past when i've
i've had any questions um you know they
refer to only a handful of people that
actually work there so you know i think
it is quite a quite a small operation um
i'd probably need to look a little bit
more into the the background as to how
they're limited but say they are
government appointed so uh the
government are the ones that would uh in
essence have to support them or bail
them out if they got into any
difficulties
yeah thank you
just sort of supplementary to that then
if the government set them up
this is a company with a limited
liability does the government take any
responsibilities
i don't know that level of detail in
terms of how they were they were set up
in the first place but i can i can take
that question away and have a look at it
thank you katherine
thank you mike
it's just a supplementary catherine have
they been going have they got a record
have they been gone for
two or three years or is it the current
government now that set them up which
might worry me
they've been going since the our audit
contract went external in 2016 so they
were set up prior to 2016 to do the last
lot of
national procurement contracts so they
have been running for a good five to six
years now
okay well that's slightly reassuring
um
mary i still have a hand up from you is
that a current
no
chair that's
yeah
um i just want to support this psa a
suggestion recommendation because while
i understand my colleagues might be
concerned
about value for money
um i think to do anything like that
locally um
we would be
restricting ourselves to skilled
professionals
and while we may have to pay for it i
think as a council we should be
supporting the best
that that is available
to undertake the audit i'm um
and locally i'm not sure that we've got
that breadth of
opportunity from local companies thank
you
yes i think we all agree with that
basically mary um james
thank you chair i think um
council norris brings quite a good point
about the um
the the limited on the end of this um
public sector audit appointments limited
um i do i would like to know a little
bit more about that but what it it did
concern me when i saw this that this
could be
a bit like a um
a mortgage provider that um
says you can um they'll you you'll have
to use
i don't know
one of four legal companies to um convey
a house or something like that you you
sometimes have to be a little bit
careful that there is
um
you know when there are other options
because
this um psaa could easily focus
on
on
certain companies and leave other ones
out and you then that would be the worry
that we're not getting value for money
but catherine has said that this
i think that was you um the chairman has
said that there's five companies that
are capable of doing this
and um if
the psaa are using every single company
that are capable of doing this
i'm quite happy
with the way this is um this is set out
it's just um i do um
i do see sometimes
with this these kind of things they um
they concentrate on
a few of the main companies and give
them all their business and um it's not
always the best value for money like
that but um if catherine could um just
reassure me on that yeah
yes thank you councillor um what um
happened last time around was that the
the contracts were split up into um
regional bids so it wasn't just one
contract that was let nationally it was
uh grouped into into different regional
areas and i think that enabled um the
big firms to to bid for what they wanted
to in terms of the contracts so there
are um i'm aware of three
four i think of the big firms that are
currently operating under this regime so
they have all managed to secure some of
that
work nationally and hence you've still
got that element of competition in the
market it hasn't all gone to just one
one of the big firms so hopefully
that'll reassure you and i'm i'm
guessing they will do something similar
with this latest uh procurement in terms
of having lots that the companies can
beat for
yeah i think that's quite reassuring and
um and other councils have actually said
quite a good point which is this is this
is a
far simpler
way of doing it than getting involved
maybe and having to push our
knowledge to um understand what we're
actually doing so yeah now i i'm
pretty happy with this thank you mr
chairman
thank you james i think we've all got a
wish to be independent and try and save
money but it would probably
end in another mess so i think um we
probably are best to go with the
professionals and um
accept and endorse this does everybody
agree with that
i just need to know if if somebody
doesn't yes
yes happy with that chair yes well i
think so um too i raised some issues but
i'm just being devil's advocate really
um
as long as and and i suppose catherine
we will get another chance to finally
accept this or is that done and dusted
as far as we're concerned we will get to
know who wins the contract and um have
some influence i take it
we will be informed and usually it's
whether we have any sort of conflict of
interest with the the
the audit firm that is being proposed
you know whether we have any other
arrangements or with them or any
contractual other than the audit work so
yes we will be notified as to who that
is
before before they are actually
appointed
yeah that's fine then okay thank you
everybody for that there's no issues um
and i think we've done our best to raise
concerns on that one i'm sure they'll be
noted
um
now item nine is the forward plan
everybody that's um last item on the
agenda today
i've had a look at that and
yes looks pretty interesting for the
next two meetings
any comments please i think did somebody
say there was a change to
one of the items was it you catherine
said there would be a change for the
march meeting is that correct
yes chair um at the moment on the march
meeting you have got the annual audit
letter for 2021 and the statement of
accounts and auditors report um i had
previously just asked that to be moved
forward to may because the auditors um
haven't started our audit of those
accounts yet so it won't be ready to
come in in march
so it's moved it's moved back to may in
in in effect then isn't it yes and
depending on when they do finally start
we may have to keep that under review
but uh we'll put it on the may one for
the time being
i think last year ended up being about
september is that correct i think
possibly july i think from memory but
yes yeah it was late yes hopefully the
pressures might be a little less um
yes and
well we'll we'll keep a watch on that um
hopefully it could be may but um prepare
uh to be surprised or not surprised
anything else um
members that um
we've only gone up to
up to the may there's nothing for well
that's the end of the council then isn't
it so um
um hopefully we'll all be here at that
time
yeah when we've had the um timetable of
meetings for the for the next year chair
i shall fill all of the forward planning
for all of the meetings ongoing
that's fine mandy thank you very much
for that well that concludes the meeting
we've given a steer and
done what we can um in this virtual
meeting thank you very much to um
everybody
um and i wish you a good day and we'll
see you soon enjoy
you